bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur tv fil 78 si vous nous rejoignez
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
un an après la généralisation et la
généralisation pardon la réforme des
rythmes scolaires sur tout le territoire
national le temps est venu de dresser un
premier bilan de cette nouvelle
organisation de l'école n'hésitez pas
chez vous à réagir sur le twitter de
l'émission hashtag 7,8 société comment
les villes les parents les enseignants
se sont ils adaptés à ces nouveaux
rythmes quel problème
ont-ils rencontré des ajustements sont
ils à prévoir pour la rentrée et surtout
question essentielle les enfants sont
ils moins fatigués et plus efficace à
l'école pour répondre à ces questions
quatre invités autour de la table sur un
gland d'abord vous êtes première
adjointe au maire de montigny le
bretonneux déléguée à la vie scolaire
pour soir jean michel fourgous maire
d'elancourt vice président de la com et
aux communautés d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et conseil
départemental des yvelines bonsoir
bonsoir
hélène caire vous êtes secrétaire de
l'association de parents d'élèves de la
pub de guyancourt bonsoir et enfin
laurent burson adjoint au maire de
maurepas déléguée à la famille à
l'enfance à la réussite scolaire et à la
jeunesse tout ça bonsoir bonsoir
alors la paix pas en cette fin d'année
avec une autre un autre syndicat parents
d'élèves l'aï pe organisé un sondage
auprès des parents pour savoir s'il
était satisfait des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires
on va en voir justement quelques
résultats et la première question vous
avez posé l équerre aux parents s'ils
pensaient que l'aménagement mise en
place pour la semaine de quatre jours et
demi
était plutôt avantageuse par rapport à
la fatigue sur les enfants est
apparemment 52% trouve que cette
organisation fatigue davantage les
enfants est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer sur le terrain pourquoi il
pense que sa fatigue plus les enfants
cette organisation des rythmes scolaires
d'abord donc le questionnaire a été
élaboré par les parents d'élèves nous
avons repris un questionnaire qui avait
été proposé par la paper nationale et
nous l'avons adapté aux questions que se
posaient les parents que nous
rencontrions au quotidien le matin
devant l'école et nous voulions faire
écrire aux parents leurs témoignages
leurs opinions pour pouvoir le porter en
mairie et pouvoir remonter des choses du
terrain que en mairie on semblait
refuser de l'entendre pour essayer
d'apporter quelques aménagements vous
attendiez comme sylvan 52%
vous pensez que c'était assez en fait le
pourcentage de participation il est le
reflet également de par exemple la
participation aux élections parents
d'élèves qui veut dire que les parents
d'élèves se sont mobilisés autant que
quand ils viennent nous témoigner leur
attachement 2770 parents / / guyancourt
et 1192 qui se sont exprimés pour qu'un
peu moins de la moitié ça fait 40 ans
car en fait c'est un petit peu différent
serre que il y à quelques enfants qui
ont deux parents et donc c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça mais il faut
retenir le chiffre de 1185 pour ensuite
calculer les taux de participation ce
qui est important c'est pas les
pourcentages qui est important c'est ce
que disent ses parents et parents
remonte effectivement une fatigue qu'il
constate c'est qu'il trouve plus
importante qu'auparavant les enseignants
également les
les ampoules femmes personnel du
périscolaire également nous on a entendu
aussi plus de conflits en cours en cours
d'école à gérer pour les enseignants
pour le périscolaire
on a entendu une pause méridienne ou des
enfants de maternelle devrait pouvoir le
faire la sieste à la maison et revenir
faire une activité où on dit bah non le
retour maternelle ce n'est pas pour
faire une activité
donc voilà des coupures de rythme qui
sont pas forcément dans l'intérêt des
enfants
alors justement vous parliez des
maternelles on a un autre camembert sur
les questions vous avez posé à d'hui en
cours et ce qui les glands courtois
pense que le nouvel aménagement du temps
scolaire et périscolaire est adapté
d'abord aux élèves de maternelle 59% de
parents qui disent non c'est pas adapté
du tout et puis pour l'école élémentaire
ses 47 %
alors pourquoi cette différence entre la
maternelle et l'élémentaire des paroles
en l'air un peu plus mécontents pour les
maternelles disons que en fait il n'y a
pas vraiment de changement dans le
contenu par rapport au temps qui a été
ajoutée et donc les parents ne voient
pas de plus value cette modification
notamment pour les parents des plus
jeunes des petits tout petit où il ya un
problème d'organisation au niveau du
temps de sieste entre les enfants qui
rentre manger à la maison les enfants
qui restent et qui est pas forcément
facilement gérés qui est gérée par les
les enseignants sur place mais qui est
pas qui est pas satisfaisant donc il en
ressort derrière une insatisfaction
générale jean michel fourgous vous aussi
avec les parents d'élèves d'elancourt
est-ce que vous avez des retours déjà de
cette première année à de généralisation
de la réforme
l'opposant force de cet été le premier
maire de france on ait promis en tout
cas à alerter l'ensemble des maires de
france de la dangerosité de cette
réforme
j'avais une idée à l'époque parce qu'il
est le coup si bien qu'elle coûterait
entre
1 et 2 milliards à l'époque le ministre
à l'époque m'avait dit hun sen pays on
m'avait dit que pas du tout ça coûterait
0 je peux vous dire aprilia 10 300
millions après 600 millions donc on en
est plutôt proche de 2 milliards
aujourd'hui moi c'est important parce
que à l'heure où les dotations des
communes s'effondre on a quand même 1000
communes qui sont quasiment sous tutelle
en france avec l'effet de la baisse des
recettes de l'état et l'augmentation des
dépenses due au rythme scolaire aussi
donc je peux vous dire que les
collectivités sont d'une situation
extrême votre ancien photos font oublier
de le dire ça bon
deuxièmement en solex sûrs maintenant
l'équipe pédagogique sacem une zizanie
dans les équipes pédagogiques
parce que d'abord nos animateurs devant
on a eu beaucoup de mal à recruter en
plus de monde y avoir je crois qu'on est
près de 180 je sais plus de 180
animateurs vous imaginez ce que c'est
d'abord de gérer ça de recruter de
former de manager afaccc travail bon de
trouver ceux qui ont les bons diplômes
et c'est bon c'est très difficile enfin
je crois qu'on a eu
les partis au djihad est en cours sur
deux communes dans les animateurs il
faut voir que c'est très compliqué on se
dit quand je pars t'éclater la qualité
du recrutement et le management ccc
cannes c'est mission impossible pour
beaucoup de communes bon surtout pour
les petites communes
quand vous demandez à un gars devenir 45
minutes et qui l'a 45 minutes de trajet
aller 45 minutes de trajet retour mais
oui la roue et où est là où elle à la
rentabilité donc c'est un vrai problème
en deuxièmement bien sûr problème entre
les profs qui eux ont maintenant sont
une vraie ont un vrai métier c'est un
métier de d'enseigner la pédagogie parce
que ça on est quand même dans le champ
de la pédagogie c'est un vrai problème
c'est un vrai problème ces deux équipes
complètement différentes compare les
mêmes objectifs qui les mêmes méthodes
ensuite les locaux
c'est le c'est le bordel le plus complet
parce que les profs eux ils veulent pas
donner une classe leur classe pour d'une
animation
parce que d'abord ça désorganise des
classes assailli retrouvent pas leurs
repères le lendemain deuxièmement ils
veulent pas ils utilisent l'été ni non
plus parce que dans l'été nier les
contenus si les animateurs qui sont pas
formés change des contenus c'est le
bordel troisièmement les tablettes
idem pour moi c'est sa propre ça
provoque un désorganisation de l'équipe
pédagogique et ça je peux vous dire
c'est bien sûr ça fait baisser les
résultats scolaires
tout pareil alors si les enfants sont
ouvertes il ya maternelle mais vous
l'avez déjà dit c'est exactement le
contraire de 2 de la promesse
on a vendu sa aux français c'est une
c'est une c'est un cetain c'est un
fiasco total sept ses formes c'est le
fiasco à elancourt b on entend au cap d
éloges sur un autre signé apparemment
montini ça se passe très bien
alors comment ça s'est passé sa chérie
régional le progrès j'étais comme une
riche jamais chez les communes riches et
les communes là il ya il faut être très
riche pour pour un c'est vrai de jours
appel à vélizy et dès qu'il ya des cours
de 2,2 de violon
non non non non non on n'est pas plus
riche qu'elle encourt donc ce qu'il ya
surtout c'est que on est parti du
principe ya bientôt enfin oui deux ans
maintenant un petit peu plus de deux ans
je crois je n'ai plus exactement la date
de la sortie du décret en tête
voilà donc oui on y est on est deux ans
en arrière et on s'est dit que puisque
le décret était sorti que ça n'était pas
une oie mais c'était un décret que donc
plutôt qu'en dire on va attendre la
dernière minute on s'est mis à
travailler avant que si peu pour
préparer le café
donc on a créé alors en plus votre débat
d'aujourd'hui tombe très bien puisque le
dernier comité de pilotage et comité
technique a eu lieu
réunis a eu lieu vendredi vendredi matin
donc j'ai vraiment des infos toutes
fraîches par rapport à tout ce qui s'est
passé
toute cette année et je crois vraiment
que le fait d'avoir travaillé comme ça
sur un an et demi en rassemblant tout le
monde
du mieux possible parce que je suis
d'accord avec toi c'est vrai que ça
n'était pas évident de faire travailler
les uns avec les autres même s'ils se
connaissent ici se côtoient animateurs
enseignants tout au long de la journée
dans les écoles et avec les atsem aussi
au niveau des maternelles ça n'était pas
évident donc ça a été un travail de
longue haleine avec les parents d'élèves
aussi un bien sûr toutes les toutes les
fédérations représentées ouais donc pour
vous ce sera plutôt marché et donc ça
plutôt marché voilà au début on a essuyé
les plâtres mais son nom était conscient
donc mais petit à petit je vous le dirai
après petit à petit voilà on a fait
sauter des verrous alors justement
partenaires pour finir ce premier tour
de table remboursons comment ça s'est
passé du côté du côté de maurepas alors
justement donc nous sommes arrivés donc
l'équipe municipale actuelle donc dont
le maire y aurait garé si nous sommes
arrivés donc aux affaires donc
l'année dernière et la force était de
constater que ben rien vouloir très peu
de choses avaient été mises en place
donc c'est vrai qu' aucun travail
voulait dire commencer par la majorité
sans concertation un peu décidé un peu
comme ça et la raison profonde oui c'est
bien ce sens puisque vous parlez
d'opposition on avait invités à venir
débattre d'autres mairies de gauche
mais voilà on n'a pas eu de réponse
c'est pour ça que elle a peut-être qu'il
manquera un petit peu de diversité
politique autour de la table pour que
les téléspectateurs besoin un grand
enthousiasme noémie de gauche 7 pour
soutenir cette réforme ont peut-être
qu'ils étaient occupés ça c'est autre
chose
monsieur besson période toujours est il
que c'est pour ça que donc bakot quand
nous sommes arrivés donc aux affaires
donc nous avions demandé enfin nous
avions refusé de mettre en place cette
réforme demander un report pour avoir le
temps de tout mettre en place pour la
rentrée qui arrive donc nous avons mis
en place malgré tout contraint et forcé
donc la réforme des rythmes scolaires
avec un scénario qui n'était pas
forcément
satisfaisant mais qui met sur lequel
nous n'avions pas le choix et donc à un
petit peu comme vous disiez donc nous
avons essuyé les plâtres
ça a démarré difficilement qui peu à peu
au fur et à mesure de l'année donc on a
organisé les choses plus facilement et
donc ça s'est amélioré au fur et à
mesure de l'année maintenant ce n'est
pas encore satisfaisant
c'est pour ça que dès septembre nous
modifions l'organisation pour pour
mettre en place des activités de qualité
en sachant que la mise en place c'est
exactement ce qu'on demandait l'année
dernière en demandant ce report c'était
sa ville s'est fait avec une
construction tout au long de l'année
j'ai moi même participé à trois cents
heures de réunion avec les parents
d'élèves les atsem les animateurs
souvent oubliée souvent oubliés des
animateurs et évidemment les enseignants
donc il reste ce que comme disait jean
michel tout à l'heure il reste des
difficultés notamment de mutualisation
des locaux avec les enseignants et les
animateurs
mais ce travail va se faire au fur et à
mesure avec notamment le dire le comité
de pilotage et période était alors
justement à part la pub de grand corps
est ce qu'il ya eu déjà des sondages
faits par la ville de montigny à
elancourt à maurepas pour voir si les
enfants étaient plus ou moins fatigués
pour voir si les instituteurs étaient
contents ou pas pour voir si les parents
étaient plutôt emballé par cette réforme
sinon sur quoi vous basez vous en faites
pour voilà pour critiquer cette réforme
il y avait un sondage permanent c'est à
dire qu'on s'est tenue à l'écouté de
tout ce qui se passait pratiquement au
quotidien on a reçu très souvent les
parents d'élèves parce que dans l école
il y avait tel problème
quelques insatisfactions et donc tout au
long de l'année on a essayé de gérer ça
voilà au mieux le
le constat à l'issue de la réunion du du
comité technique comité de pilotage de
vendredi dernier le constat il ya celui
de la fatigue bien évidemment ça c'est
unanime que ce soit nos animateurs que
ce soit les enseignants que ce soit les
parents d'élèves et ce malgré ce
qu'annonçaient les médecins qui ont été
en relation et qui met tous les plateaux
télé tout le reste est positif
vraiment positif ou en quelques petites
amer amélioration bien sûr important ça
c'est normal mais sinon tout le reste
est très positif
le les bonnes relations entre les uns et
les autres on a fait en sorte que
justement la mutualisation des locaux se
passe bien on avait fait un séminaire à
la fin de l'année 2013
un séminaire entre les directeurs de nos
écoles et nos directeurs de centres de
manière à ce que déjà les uns les autres
prenez le faisait passer toute une
journée ensemble rien qu'en semble
ailleurs que dans le lieu habituel ça
change un petit peu la tournure des
choses
donc ça voilà il n'y a pas eu de gros
soucis sur ce sujet vraiment la seule
chose c'est effectivement le constat tic
de confiance at il alors si ça marche
alors signé qu'est ce que ça marche
comme ça faut être sérieux
non mais ça coûte ça coûte près d'un
million d'euros avec 1 million d'euros
mais bien sûr une collectivité peut même
organiser les cours gérance on sait
faire un haussement là mais faut voir
c'est qu'elle est le plus de cette
réforme que ça apporte aux enfants par
rapport aux coûts enfin il ya un sondage
qui était fait par le le syndicat des
enseignants c'est près de 17000
enseignants qui montrent moins 14
personnes enseignants jugent l'impact
négatif sur les enfants et sur eux mêmes
les profs deuxièmement alors j'en
profite mais je ne comprends plus rien
il me semblait que tout le monde était
plutôt unanimes pour dire que la journée
de 4 le rythme de quatre jours c'était
trop chargé pour les enfants tout le
monde appelait de ses voeux la journée
de quatre jours et demi et maintenant
tout le monde dit que ça fatigue plus de
jeu comment écouter les profs en tout
cas qui sont les monde de soccer c'est
plus de fatigue pour les enfants quand
même bon un succès construit il ya une
baisse de la tension sur le temps
pendant la classe il ya les locaux bien
sûr qui on est
mal à trouver des locaux nommés tant
mieux pour montigny c'est vraiment un
succès monstre us et de ses réformes
dégradation des conditions de travail
des enseignants la qualité bon tant
mieux quand on a effectivement quand on
met des moyens
effectivement mais une commune peut même
tout de même prendre en charge les
élèves et se passer de l'éducation
nationale si on nous donne le budget
ollier aucun problème on sait faire mais
quel est le plus de cette réforme c'est
comme ça la question
donc ce n'est pas cinq ils se sont
engagés les inégalités ont pu se
renforcer aujourd'hui entre des petites
communes rurales nous je paye vélizy
vélizy donne des cours de violon
bon comme tu dis d'ailleurs avant
c'était avant même la réforme alors que
d'autres communes
alors la trappe c'est une catastrophe
trappe c'est quand même la ville du
ministre a lancé ça et on nous
promettait pendant un an des cours de
théâtre ça c'est suffisant de dire des
cours de taza est super bon ça finit par
la balle au prisonnier à la cour bon
bien que nommé on peut pas on peut pas
dire soit soissons a les moyens et on
donne les moyens aux collectivités ou
les communes ont des moyens auparavant
enfin on peut pas dire que je ne sais
pas si ça va tout ça va bien amélioré ce
que veulent les parents c'est qu'on
améliore les résultats scolaires des
enfants ou de la sspa dans les
meilleures conditions c'est pas c'est
pas le cas je vous rappelle qu'on est
quand même très mal classés dans le
plasma nationaux c'est pas ça qui va
améliorer notre c'est encore trop court
pour dire si ça marche je rappelle une
dernière chausse-trappes québécoise en
nombre deux trappes a plus d'expérience
si son deuxième exploit
ga que bon encore ils en sont maintenant
alors qu'ils avaient promis la gratuité
c'est une ville assez pauvre tramont ma
vie il maintenant exemption à faire
payer donc
donc si on est riche rationner les
moyens on peut garder l'enfant handicapé
si on n'a pas les moyens en cas de
retour nous de récupérer son enfant
on peut pas dire que ce soit quand même
un succès monstrueux en france voilà aux
lilas problème avec les communes riches
maintenant tel commencer la potennerie
tanguy d'abord
d'abord monsieur bursaux puis après
hélène caire qui voulaient réagir
oui parade par rapport à la fatigue de
l'enfant je partage ce qui a été dit
effectivement les enfants semblent plus
sautille et enfin le fait que j'aille à
tous les conseils d'école je peux le
constater
enfin les parents d'élèves le disent les
enseignants le dise maintenant sur
certaines écoles on a vu des
organisations qui faisaient que
effectivement les enfants avaient une
certaine
plus grande facilité à retourner à
l'enseignement après le repas du midi
tout dépendait de ce qui avait été fait
justement sur ce temps d'état donc c'est
effectivement encore une fois j'étais
opposé à cette réforme mais
bon on peut on laisser voter on n'a pas
le choix c'est voter on n'a pas le choix
maintenant voter c'est pas voter c'est
pas une loi ou un décret d'un décret
c'est un décret il faut l'appliquer et
donc maintenant il faut l'appliquer le
mieux possible effectivement avoir pas
parce qu'on a ce côté avec municipal qui
d'ailleurs même pas dire l'enseignement
l'éducation est une de ses priorités
notamment le donc rénovation des écoles
etc
nous avons souhaité effectivement bien
faire en sorte que ben cette réforme vu
qu'elle est là la mettre en place avec
donc des moyens de qualité ça va
commencer vraiment de manière plus c'est
j'irai en septembre puisque va y faire
intervenir pendant ces étapes des
éducateurs sportifs notamment des
associations de l'argent supplémentaire
de l'argent supplémentaire effectivement
puisqu'on va être aux alentours sur une
année pleine l'année prochaine pour mort
pas qu'ils aient moins de 2000 élèves à
400000 euros le coût le coup d'état donc
ce qu'ils ont augmenté les impôts sans
augmenter les impôts ce qui veut dire
d'en faire des choix automatiquement
faire des choix mais en général c'est la
culture
non non non non c'est pas sûr mort pas
c'est pas la culture
vous avez toujours un café de la plage
par exemple dont je suis aussi donc
niveau de la jeunesse allemand voilà et
est donc albert camus qui présente une
saison qui est fort riche et d'ailleurs
qui qui est ouverte aussi aux enfants et
aux écoles donc elle est fière de ce qui
va changer aussi de ce que vous
souhaitez changer pour la rentrée je
trouve qu'on parle beaucoup d'argent
alors ce sont des élus c'est leur
préoccupation principale mais les
enfants leur préoccupation s'est joué à
cet âge là qu'elle élémentaire la
maternelle et la provocation des
préoccupations des parents c'est que
leurs enfants soient bien accueillis
avec un encadrement nombre suffisant
qualifiés donc dans la non de la
compétence et la compétence n'est pas
qu'une question d'argent
et puis qu'il y ait effectivement les
locaux adaptés vous le dites mais on a
en général dans les écoles
du secteur plutôt des locaux très bien
fait c'est qu'une question de partage
donc de concertation de travail pour que
ce qui se fait en périscolaire soient
valorisés du côté enseignants et vice
versa parce que ce n'est pas toujours le
cas et il manque beaucoup de
concertation entre les deux équipes est
par exemple moi j'ai constaté le le
manque de coordination entre le retour
enfin de pause méridienne
vers la classe qui génère surexcitation
alors qu'on est censé faire un temps
calme enfin de pause méridienne pour
favoriser le retour aux apprentissages
pour favoriser un temps calme parce que
c'est la digestion et qu'on ne peut pas
forcément faire un temps d'apprentissage
à la rentrée je ne sais pas c'est aussi
une concertation entre les deux équipes
fait que les uns croient que c'est le
bazar
pendant la pause méridienne et qu'on n'a
aucune considération pour le temps
d'apprentissage au retour en classe et à
linverse le périscolaire n'a pas
forcément fait savoir où fait et
valoriser son investissement sur ben on
a récupéré les enfants de la cour les a
mis sur des temps calmes et des
activités jeux société tant qu'allemand
bibliothèque etc
c'est transparent les équipes se
croisent dans les couloirs s'intéressent
pas forcément y'a pas vraiment
l'interfaçage c'est indispensable ils
travaillent ensemble avec les mêmes
enfants donc c'est quelque chose dans
les points à améliorer qui pour nous sur
l'huile en cours nous paraît évident
sous un blanc rapidement peu après
laurent version wii dites moi qu'est ce
qui va changer à la rentrée
qu'est ce qui va changer à la rentrée
alors le le fait que jusqu'à présent
nous sortions amedi à la demande
générale
on a fait un avenir au pdt et les
enfants sortiront à 11h30
et pourquoi ce qu'ils mangent dit alors
six allemands alors à l'origine parce
que l'emploi du temps avaient été
établis tels quels
les deux comités est accepté tel quel
sauf pour les petits des petites
sections de maternelle et les moyens de
les petits de moyenne section de
maternelle puisque sur le département il
y avait une dérogation qui faisait que
ces petits là pouvaient ce qui restera
cantine sortir 11h30
bon et puis c'est un peu ça un peu
dépourvu voilà bon bref donc tout le
monde est sorti à midi et le constat
général c'est que à midi les enfants ne
peuvent plus qu'ils soient petits moyens
ou grands
donc on revient sur 11h30 en rajoute une
demi-heure par contre l'après midi parce
que là ce qui nous est expliqué par les
équipes enseignantes et on le comprend
c'est que une heure pour retravailler de
façon sereine et fructueuse
c'est un petit peu complétée au cours
voilà donc ce sera une heure trente de
nouveaux l'après midi laurent blanc
voulait réagir a fait réagir les
nacelles effectivement vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que
quand il ya un temps retour au calme sur
le temps du midi avant l'enseignement
effectivement les enfants reprennent de
manière plus apaisée et l'enseignement
de l'après midi est riche c'est
exactement ce que je détale heures dans
certaines écoles de maurepas c'est où ça
fonctionne bien c'est exactement ça
c'est la partie on en met en place un
temps comment c'est le bouquin c'est le
bouquin serre chez nous c'est pas aussi
évident que ça nous les enfants quand
ils sont tous mis dans les mains du
scolaire et retourne dans la cour voilà
ton dos et ça redémarre et donc ensuite
j'ai le cas d'une école où on a supprimé
la récréation tout à fait dans la cour
pour favoriser un temps plus calme et la
maîtresse des crêtes à quelle heure elle
veut faire le temps de récréation qui
est donc plus une pause qu'une
récréation les enfants ne sortent pas
dans la cour ne descendent pas non pas
mettre les manteaux et cetera donc on a
gagné une demi heure et on reste entre
soi tant qu'à l'hôpital
on est entre nous donc il ya un effet
aussi c'est pour social ça c'est des
informations
il n'y a pas forcément de coordination
après bon sur les enseignants sont son
meilleur juge mais il ya des enfants qui
ont besoin malgré tout de se dépenser il
ya des grands qui ont besoin de faire de
l'activité physique pour évacuer les
apprentissages et les parents ont du mal
à comprendre que ben on reste fermée
dans la classe tout l'après-midi à la
fin de cette émission et puis vous aurez
un petit mot de conclure moi je dirais
simplement que l'urgence nos parents ils
veulent bien sûr les meilleures
conditions de travail pour leurs enfants
et surtout les meilleurs résultats pour
améliorer les scolaires il faut
renforcer la formation des profs c'est
là où il faudrait mettre l'argent c'est
avoir des nouveaux supports techniques
faux et faire évoluer cette pédagogie
française qui est beaucoup trop frontal
trop magistral qui ennuie quelquefois
les ans fils de numérique pour la faire
avec des outils modernes comme le numéro
et voilà c'est les 2 milliards fait les
mecs là ça on perd du temps et donc je
reprends la phrase de du dernier
ministre le surnom qu'il vient conclure
que c'est un immense bénéfice pour les
enfants alors on garde le sens de
l'humour avec la phrase bien sûr
l'habituel dimensionnement et son sens
de la vérité
un immense bénéfice pour les enfants bon
c'est pas tout à fait comme on verra sur
des sondages et des études qui sont
faites quand même sur les professeurs
l'identité nationale a annoncé
l'évolution dès la rentrée sur les
résultats scolaires et sent la fatigue
donc on verra ce un bout de deux ans on
vous réalisant on va voir seulement une
évaluation alors que tous nos enfants
sont engagés dans les mairies qui en
sont en difficulté financière
vous imaginez seulement attendre vous
donnons de déclarer qu'on va faire une
étude d'impact on s'en sert rapidement
vraiment pour conclure lorsque je vois
ce que je voudrais donc pour finir dire
c'est que cette réforme
il vient d'en haut c'est très très
compliqué à mettre en place
c'est pas une histoire de coup c'est une
histoire d'organisation déjà et c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment dommage de que
ça se soit passé comme ça parce que à
partir du moment où comme on a fait
cette année on fait de la concertation
comme j'ai dis avec les animateurs les
parents d'élèves etc
on arrive à quelque chose qui va
commencer à donner de l'intérêt pour
cette cette réforme mais il a fait deux
ans qu'on ne s'en soient leurs diane
aurait peut-être pu faire autrement
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à ce dernier débat de la
saison merci
c'était très intéressant merci à toute
l'équipe de tv fils la rédaction des
équipes techniques bien sûr on se
retrouve à la rentrée pour de nouvelles
aventures
vous l'avez remarqué il faisait très
chaud sur le plateau donc bon été à tous